howdy y'all welcome to better than food
book reviews I'm your host Cliff
Sergeant it's a beautiful slightly
chilly day here in Los Angeles and I am
very happy to be reviewing Cormac
McCarthy's Sury dear friend now in the
dusty clockless hours of the town when
the streets lie black and steaming in
the wake of the water trucks and now
when the drunk and the homeless have
washed up in the Lee of walls and alleys
or abandoned lots and cats go forth high
shouldered and lean in the Grim
perimeters about now in these soot black
brick or cobbled corridors where light
wire Shadows make a Gothic harp of
Cellar Doors no soul shall walk save
you Suri is a Southern Gothic novel of
the finest variety by what in my who in
my opinion
is the greatest living American Author
if we have one uh and that would be Mr
Cormac McCarthy Bleak and dissonant are
words that are often used to describe
McCarthy's work but I'd like to
distinguish between the writing and the
narrative The Narrative at times the
story may seem Bleak let's face it but
uh the writing is anything anything
anything
but I haven't read this like in like
something like five years you know I
must have been like 20 or 21 when I
first read this I think I read it uh
around the same time I read Blood
Meridian but um skimming over the first
few pages which that passage I just read
from is that that is the very beginning
um I remember a lot more than I thought
I did almost in like a synesthetic kind
of way there's so much talk of light and
Shadow and texture and the film off of
these fishes but we'll get to that okay
the pros is saturated right it's flooded
and like bleeding bleeding with textural
sensation it almost physically sweats
every possible combination of words to
elicit a sickening yet magnificently
Rich image seems to have been tried all
juices have been rung from the literary
Rag and it just kind of clings to you
like cigar smoke the setting is
Knoxville Tennessee in 195 51 where all
good stories start of course under a
bridge down by the river our character
is Sury who is a fisherman living on a
dilapidated house booat under this
bridge that spans the absolutely filthy
Tennessee
River he goes out on a little skiff to
go and catch catfish for a little bit of
money so this is from a
1992 I read this interview from 1992
with corm M McCarthy and this is pretty
great his characters are often outcasts
destitute or criminals or both homeless
or squatting in HS without electricity
they scrape by In the Backwoods of East
Tennessee or on Horseback in the dry
vacant spaces of the desert death which
announces itself often reaches down from
the Open Sky abruptly with a slashed
throat or a bullet in the face the abyss
opens up at any misstep and that is true
in cormic McCarthy's novels but thing
about Suri is it's
actually very
funny Suri left a life of wealth and
also a family um including a wife and a
child and traded it in for a very simple
one living on a house boat and catching
fish slowly but surely you are
introduced to this web this network of
characters that he knows from around
Knoxville and there's often these
meditations on mortality obviously
it reads the way old cracked vintage
sepia photos of the south in the 1950s
look
right I'm always fascinated by works
that make the ugly beautiful and the
Beautiful ugly and
not you know pie writing that is not
palatable or
compromised writing in bed is not
necessarily palatable or compromised
not like assimilated or sublimated but
more so of confusing these two extreme
Sensations when you're operating on this
contradictory level right and you're
reading these lines about used condoms
floating in the river roiling slowly out
of the Merc like some giant form of
fluke or tapeworm and it's some of the
most beautiful poetry put from pen to
page I mean
it's the Watcher's face rode beside the
boat a sepia vage yawing in the scum
eyes veering and watery Grimace a wel
curled sluggishly on the river's surface
as if something unseen had stirred in
the depths and small bubbles of gas
erupted in oily Spectra so basically you
know there's a suicide off of this
bridge that Suri uh lives under there's
a guy who jumps uh and the book starts
when they fish him out uh the next
morning uh and Suri spots the policemen
and everybody they like fishing like
literally like fishing this dude out of
the water uh who jumped and you know
that kind of like starts the whole the
whole variations on a theme again Cormac
like the pros refuses to be
compromised
and the novel is supposed to
be in they at least partially
autobiographical how much of it I
couldn't say of course but McCarthy is
notorious notoriously hardworking at not
working what I mean by that is McCarthy
can't stand the idea of a normal career
a normal traditional 9 to-5 job and so
on the idea of living your life being
told what to do instead of doing what
you damn well
please in every single way I feel the
same so he's kind of a kind of a mentor
so to
speak I don't think he'd like that
though you have one brief often
ridiculous Bal boring disappointing
astonishing bizarre cruel and beautiful
hopefully somewhat
fulfilling
life that will end tomorrow or maybe in
60 or 70 years why the [__] why the [__]
would you spend that time being told
what to do by anybody else if you could
help it that was probably the first
question I seriously asked myself when I
was kind of entering into the teenage
years of course not everybody is so
lucky to have it work for them things
fall through through poverty disease
Misfortune bad decisions addiction
shitty family you've all heard the story
Etc in an interview in what might be the
only public television interview he's
ever done with Oprah of all people um he
tells her that his biggest priority was
simply not to work right poverty doesn't
frighten McCarthy and that much can be
ascertained from his literature
undoubtedly nor does and I have a lot of
respect for this nor does the idea of
taking his time right he wrote Suri on
and off for 20
years you would be amazed to find that
the hands responsible for this writing
are not calloused and cut and scabbed
and bleeding right it feels so visceral
and so hard and so lived but for all the
fer and Hemingway and his style
there's just as much Shakespeare
and like two rivers that have been
separated and running parallel for
thousands and thousands and thousands of
miles they finally meet together and it
Blends and flows to
become uh stronger than
ever Su is one man's meditation it seems
at times on being alone right being
alone in this world that is nauseating
and gorgeous at the same time so through
his conversations with the locals which
range from like bums to witches to
criminals to you name it you know we are
given one of the greatest meditations on
mortality that Western literature has to
offer yes it's all about death I know I
sound like a broken record sometimes but
if you're going to read something that
is worth reading that is serious you
know it's probably going to be about Sex
and Death the only two things worth
talking about as Peter Greenway the
amazing British film director would put
it the night is quiet like a camp before
battle the city beset by a thing unkown
known and will it come from forest or
sea the mingers have walled the pale the
gates are shut below the things inside
and can you guess his shape where he's
kept or what's the counter of his face
is he a weaver bloody shuttle shot
through a Time Warp a Carter of souls
from the world's nap or a hunter with
hounds or do bone horses draw his dead
Court through the streets and does he
call his trade to each dear friend he is
not to be dwelt upon for it is by just
such wise that he's invited
in love that love that another one of my
favorite lines is when another one of my
favorite lines is when Suri brings a
catfish to this old homeless man who's
uh cooking potatoes in this fire under
the bridge in kind of this recessed
Cavern and they're discussing the
suicide that happened that day and uh
the old man swears he'd never jump off
the bridge
but he says they say that death comes
like a thief in the night where is he
I'll hug his
neck I always remember that line for
some reason I just thought it was
brilliant now I know you know now I did
say it was funny I mean up until now
there's a lot of darkness and there is a
lot of darkness and there should be a
lot of darkness in his work I mean it's
cor M McCarthy but um
the book alone is worth it for the
friend the story of Jean harget who was
Suri's friend who was caught by a farmer
in the middle of the night uh in his
water patch [__] his
watermelons to have that kind of gift
and that kind of sensibility to write a
poetic passage about a kid [__]
watermelons is I mean you know that's
one of a kind I mean that is damn genius
I just can't help but read it to you
there there were no more than a quarter
acre of them a long black rectangle set
along the edge of the Corn in which by
the meager Starlight of late summer he
could see the plump form Supine and
dormant in spaced Rose he listened in
the distance a dog was yapping and in
his Keen ears the blind passage of Gat
sounded incessantly he knelt in the rich
and steaming Earth his nostrils filled
with the whiny smell of ruptured melons
to steal upon them where they lay his
hand on their warm right Shades his
pocket knife open he lifted one a pale
Jade underbelly turning up he pulled it
between his knees and sank the blade of
the knife into its nether end he shucked
off the straps of his overalls his pale
Shanks kneeling in a pool of denim a
whipper will had began to call and with
his ear to the ground this way he began
to hear the train too a star arked long
and dying down the sky he raised his
head and looked toward the house nothing
moved the train had come on and her
Harpy throat at High bell wailed down
the lonely summer night he could hear
the wheels shucking along the rails and
he could feel the ground shudder and he
could hear the tone of the truck shift
at the Crossing and the huffing breath
of the boiler and the Rattle and Clank
and wheel click and couple clacking and
then the last long shunting on the
downgrade drawing on toward the distance
and the low moan balling across the
sleeping land and fading and the Caboose
clicking away to final silence he rose
and adjusted his clothes and went back
along the rows of corn to the woods and
to the road and set himself toward home
again and later on later on after the
farmer has spotted him but was unable to
catch him in the middle of the night and
now relating the story to this friend of
his right two pairs of Broan went along
the rows you ain't going believe this
knowing you for a born liar I most
probably won't somebody has been [__]
my
watermelons what I said somebody had no
no hell no damn you if you ain't got a
work M I'm telling you I don't want to
hear it look at here they went along the
outer row of the melon patch he stopped
to nudge a melon with his toe Yellow
Jackets snarled in the seepage some were
ruined a good time past and lay soft
with Rod wrinkled with imminent collapse
it does look like a donut I'm telling
you I seen him I didn't know what the
hell was going on but when he dropped
his drawers that's when I seen what he
was up to I still didn't believe it but
Yonder they lay what do you aim to do
hell I don't know it's about too late to
do anything he's damn near screwed the
whole patch I don't see why he couldn't
have stuck to just one or a few well I
guess he takes himself for a lover sort
of like a sailor in a whouse I reckon
what it was was he didn't take to the
idea getting bit on the head of the
pecker by one of them waspers suppose he
showed good judgment there
so Sury and the melon guy actually meet
in this work Camp basically when they're
in jail because you know that's where
they put people who hump melons So
eventually of course everybody finds out
what Jean's been doing and why he's in
jail and uh you know he's trying to
explain it to Suri he says they tried to
get me for beast beast beastiality yeah
but my L told him a watermelon wasn't no
Beast he was a smart son of a
[__] it's better than food
it's better than
watermelons all right you want the
soundtrack to accompany I'd say the
album blind Joe death by John fahe
excellent excellent guitar
um and the first Nick Cave album
particularly the song Saint Huck which
is one long intense ramble if I ever
heard one
um yeah the album from her to
Eternity brilliant brilliant album
anyways those two just go hand inand
with Suri for me
um and as if you needed another uh
reason to read Blood Meridian I there's
a little thing I forgot when I was doing
that review I didn't even talk once
about the scene where the mules are
carrying the sacks of mercury across the
cliff and they start falling off and
exploding in this Canyon of blood and
silver going everywhere oh man like I
mean as if you needed another reason
right you know read that damn book so
uh so
uh Merry
Christmas yeah subscribe donate on
patreon if you you are feeling generous
this holiday season and uh please follow
the Amazon affiliate link below to buy
all the books or to just buy anything
whatever you buy if you follow the link
I get a little Kickback and I really
appreciate it you know I hope you have a
wonderful happy New Year and please this
Christmas always remember the Gospel of
John Waters that is if you go home with
someone and they don't have books don't
[__] them have a great day guys talk to
you next week ciao